Tiffany is with us in Atlanta Georgia
hi Tiffany how are you how are you doing
better than I deserve what's up and I
was calling because I want to get your
advice
please financial peace a couple years
ago but we also have a lot of burdens as
far as fit so we have about 300 and
something thousand of student loans
whoa stop stop three hundred thousand
and student loans
yes who's the doctor or lawyer nobody's
a doctor a lawyer is just a lot of
expensive food
what are your degrees in honey
business and leadership oh my lord what
is your household income 140 thousand
that's that's good news
oh my goodness overpaid for some degrees
okay ouch
three hundred thousand student loans and
what else talking about sixties between
medical and car things like this what do
you owe on the cars like 1501 about
eleven on another okay all right well I
mean you've got a very very tight budget
you got a lot of house and you got a lot
of cars and you are deeply in student
loan debt so one of two things is going
to occur you're going to sell cars and
houses and move down into just some
junky cars and into a little rental
property and you're gonna use the
hundred and forty to get rid of the
student loan debt or you're going to
keep the house and the cars and you're
going to limp out of this and it's going
to take you a lot longer so when I do
the math to things like saint-pierre
season sort of put you know get it close
now we also do qualify for a loan
forgiveness I mean after ten years
nonprofit yep after ten years great yeah
I don't want to wait ten years to be out
of debt
no I mean you make a hundred and forty
okay you've got three hundred plus you
said another sixty see you 360
I mean if we do if we put 60,000 a year
on it's done in six years if we put if
we put eighty on it it's done in four
and a half and that means you ought to
be able to do that you're just living on
nothing but I mean but I mean again I if
I were in your shoes I'm gonna move way
down in house I'm gonna sell my house
and I'm probably gonna sell the $15,000
car maybe the eleven and just get me a
couple Junkers and because I've won out
of this mess and I wouldn't want to wait
six years and those cars in that house
are gonna delay it's gonna add two years
at least to this program maybe three
maybe three and you just you guys have
bought everything in sight and couch I'm
so sorry I'm sorry you're facing all
this but I mean you can do it either way
it's whatever you want to do but you're
right you're looking at eight six to
eight years if you stay in the house and
you're probably looking at a really
tough three and a half or four if you
don't stay in the house what is the
what's the trajectory of your career
look like income wise are you seeing
incomes increase pretty dramatically or
or just slightly
um sake increases you know as you change
got like four different companies so
sicily yeah like about another twenty
thousand probably would coming the next
emotion or something like that okay
alright so that's a pretty decent push
and so you know if we project out three
years maybe we're not dealing with one
forty maybe we're dealing with one
eighty or 190 at that point on income
and see that starts to change the
equation too but you guys have you guys
have really I mean you you're broke
you're desperately broke and you're
gonna start making some dramatic moves
in cutting lifestyle and some dramatic
moves in living on the cheap to clean
this mess up and you know that that's
what you've got to do there so thanks
for the call I wish I wish I had better
answers for you but those numbers are
just horrendous sorry you're facing that
one of the things you should get from
this show other than entertainment value
is you should be learning something and
it should occur to you to think to
yourself how in the crap do people go
$300,000 in debt to get a couple of
business degrees what has to be broken
in the process they were using in order
to let yourself do that okay well let me
tell you a couple things that are broken
potentially I don't know what happened
exactly there but I'll tell you what ran
in what we're honest in my mind when I
hear those kinds of numbers for
something for a situation like that
number one people think getting a degree
from a certain school is going to more
likely ensure their success there is no
data none anywhere that indicates that
prestige schools create a higher success
probability that's just straight-up BS
it's straight-up BS as a matter of fact
more CEOs of Fortune 500 companies
graduated from public universities than
from prestige universities Wall Street
Journal did a study about two years ago
and published it made everybody mad in
that world now I don't mind you going to
a prestigious school but don't go
$300,000 in debt to get two business
degrees that's stupid okay
and because it doesn't ROI it just
simply doesn't honor oh I forgot sex is
a business degree you ought to think
about this you know and so I don't mind
you going to Wharton I don't mind you
going to Harvard I don't mind you going
to Yale or Vanderbilt I don't mind you
going to those days long as you can
write check and go or they're paying for
it it's a free ride but this idea you're
gonna go hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt because of where you
went to school and that's gonna ROI
there's no data to support your stupid
set of assumptions there none whatsoever
no research at all you cannot find it on
the planet now there's some old boys
sitting around you know sipping on
something at the country club that'll
tell you otherwise but they got nothing
to support it I'll just tell you the
second thing that happens there is if
you come from a background if your
family is not an educator
oriented family and you're the first of
your family to go get an education
sometimes you believe the lie that says
just get an education it's worth it
whatever you do you got to break the
family change you got to break the cycle
you got to do whatever and whatever it
takes you go get that education and
it'll eat you know the only shot you got
it got about not being like the rest of
us about getting out of the family tree
the only shot you got a break in the
curse on the family as education it's
the only shot education is the answer to
everything
well it's not education is important
knowledge is important but education is
not a magic pill and it is not worth
breaking yourself for the next decade to
get to business degrees unless that
couple's heart feel so sorry for it what
a mess that they're in and it's one of
those two assumptions that probably got
them there or both put together Paris
don't let your children their stuff like
that stop
make better choices on where they go to
school what you pay for your degree this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]